hello everyone my name is troy skinner
thanks for coming today I work at
immersive where we created
self-determination theory which is the
leading science framework worldwide for
understanding motivation and behavior
our founding group which you can tell by
these numbers is very old has over 350
published papers and 100 plus years of
combined experience and applying work
our model is used or referenced more
than 30,000 times per year hether
academics use it there's research across
tons of domains so if you ever need some
bedtime reading there's lots of
information to find on the net after
this talk and then where I focus is on a
unique practice at the intersection of
software and motivation consulting on 50
plus app projects a year essentially
what we go in is talk to developers talk
about design throughout ways to increase
engagement by using good behavioral
science practices attention that you see
a lot of times in design conversations
is between business objectives you're
trying to focus on bringing down churn
raising subscriptions very laudable
goals that are important to our
businesses and being customer cert first
which obviously is an aspiration if you
care about who uses your applications
and this is very natural tension but we
found in our work that it doesn't have
to be the exciting news coming out of
our decades of research is that when you
really focus on satisfying consumers
fundamental basic psychological needs it
increases their value for the
application and that increased value
shows up and all the outcome metrics are
important to our businesses you see a
reduced churn see greater engagement see
greater monetization kind of where we
fit in the pitchers obviously we've
gotten very good as an industry at
building applications lots of them are
in the world
we've gotten very good at collecting
behavioral data so we know if there's
good outcomes in our apps or bad
outcomes in our apps but where there's
kind of a black boxes in the middle
about why people do what they do so what
we do at immersive is we really focus on
understanding why people do the things
they do with
occasions not only understanding it but
measuring it with really concrete
discrete granular metrics and then
helping use that information to make
better design decisions about how to
improve apps self-determination theory
is again focused on fundamental human
psychology so kind of the underpinnings
of that is that every human all of us
everyone in this room has three basic
fundamental psychological needs which
I'll get into in more detail later but
we also look at things like intrinsic
versus extrinsic motivation goals and
motives which are essential to long-term
engagement mindfulness vitality it's a
robust comprehensive model of motivation
so it has a lot of different nooks and
crannies not all of which we'll get into
today also because it's about
fundamental human motivation it travels
to a lot of different contexts I do a
lot of work in entertainment software we
work with world-class athletic programs
avoid athletes burnout we work in
education we work in retirement because
it's about humans it's not you know
trapped in any domain so it works across
all applications because if humans use
it then motivation applies so know let's
actually get to the topic at hand
something that you see a lot when people
talk about motivation is that more is
better that we want to essentially get
people to act by you know giving them
full of motivation and kind of seeing
this humorous picture that if you have
an exercise app and your plan is that
everyone chased by t-rex you'd certainly
get lots of running but that probably
wouldn't lead to long term engagement
and once the terror subsided the right
way to think about motivation is not
that you want more it's about what the
quality of the motivation is so quality
of motivation is more important than
quantity of motivation which kind of
brings us to a continuum that I'll lay
out here for you guys
essentially if you look at we can
measure these things if you look at what
people are experiencing in your app
there's basically low motivation that
you know ranges from they don't
they're through filling external
pressure to engage in the app internal
pressure which means I feel like I
should do it I feel guilt or shame to do
it or personal value which means I have
a good reason a strong rationale for
engaging the app to intrinsic value
which is like I just love running or I
just love using this app these are all
different categories of motivation and
they lead to very different outcomes on
the kind of bottom you see that low
quality motivation leads the less
engagement lower productivity less
learning everything that we care about
and in contrast high motivation leads to
great outcomes so why is this useful
well what we do is we measure individual
users the quality of their motivation
and it allows us to basically customize
our content to meet consumers where they
are motivationally so if someone has low
quality motivation they don't really
have a good rationale for using your app
then some of your strategies might be to
essentially communicate to them where
they might find more personal value in
the application if in contrast someone's
already in love with the application you
don't need to convince them to use it
instead you continue to empower what's
driving that intrinsic value showing
them increased opportunities essentially
and also avoiding undermining that
motivation by being very mechanistic in
your design and I'll kind of explain
what that means more so now let's get
into the theory there are three basic
psychological needs needs is the
important word here they're not once in
the same way that hunger is a
physiological need so someone in the
room might say sorry I don't believe in
hunger I'm not a hunger guy it doesn't
matter if you believe in it or not if
you don't eat you'll starve to death
same thing with psychological needs if
these aren't fulfilled then you
essentially starve psychologically it
works across cultures across genders
across ages it fundamentally will turn
but in the same way that hunger does so
what are these needs the first ones
autonomy this is our need to feel like
we're the author of our life of our
experience were the one driving the
action the opposite of autonomy is
feeling controlled or manipulated by
someone or
education what you want to think about
during development when trying to design
for increased autonomy is first focus on
features that help users build a
personal narrative of value for your
application essentially a way to think
about it is you're always trying to get
people to form long term goals not take
actions based upon very short-term
motivations the underpinning of
long-term goal formation is why am I
doing this
what's my rationale how will this help
me how will this aid me so that
communication has to be enormously clear
the office of that is essentially a
carrots and sticks approach which is
something you want to avoid this is
things like rewards badges time pressure
those kinds of things that get people to
take actions it's not that rewards can't
be an important part of motivation but
they have to be subordinate to people
having a personal narrative if there's
something they want to accomplish and
they take meaningful steps towards that
and you reward them that's awesome if
they don't have that personal narrative
and essentially you're trying to
generate actions all through carrots and
sticks that's gonna lead to short-term
improvement in behavior but midterm and
long-term problems and so it's important
which foundation you're building on the
last thing is is when possible you want
to provide meaningful choices about how
to interact with the app like what value
they get out of things because
essentially if people get choices then
obviously it's easier for them to
endorse the path to run because they're
helping to design what their experiences
ii need is our need for relatedness this
is our need to meaningfully connect with
other people to feel like they matter to
us we mattered in to them things to
think about during development there's
lots of mistakes that happen in kind of
social realm around relatedness is that
it's not about it's kinda like the more
is not better it's not about how many
connections you have on LinkedIn it's
about the quality of the relationships
that you have with people within the
application so what you want to catalyze
is meaningful support where you see real
improvement in metrics and behavior is
when people feel like they matter to one
another so it's how do you build those
relationships allow people to
meaningfully support one another do
things like collaborate together on a
shared project have shared goals
coordinate mentorship relationships or a
big deal if someone's expert
the topic can they help someone that's
less expert that's meaningful to both
parties those are the kinds of
relationships you're trying to bring
about another thing that's very common
in app development is you see that
people will take an action the app and
it'll get shared out to their social
network it's not always the best policy
once we worked on a exercise of weight
loss app that had the brilliant idea
that every time you gained weight to
tell everyone you've ever met that you
just ate a lot of food in Berlin not
really the best communication for your
social identity so it's like there's the
kind of an automatic assumption that any
sharing is good but you always have to
think about it from the Sherriff's
perspective everything you say is not
necessarily something they want out
there which brings us the last thing
what people are fundamentally trying to
do in most applications is create a
social identity that basically
celebrates what they're good at what
makes them different like essentially
what's distinct about them those are the
messages they want delivered I don't
want people to know that I gained 5
pounds I want people to know that I got
to give a talk at you know Google Play
these are exciting things so you really
want to identify what narrative people
are trying to write that has social
impact and kind of communicate that for
them the last need which is often the
easiest to understand is our need for
confidence this is our honor to be
effective to be masterful to grow tends
to be very intuitive to everyone that
works in development because obviously
if your app is not accessible people
can't use it then obviously they fail at
high rates so during development one of
the things that we see people have the
most trouble with is when giving
feedback to users as it's important to
be informational rather than judgemental
so let's say that I'm picking up an
exercise app and I instantly don't know
how to do a push-up
which is likely then if you essentially
flashed a big red light and say you have
failed that push-up that makes me feel
incompetent and not really want to stick
with the exercise in contrast if I get
informational feedback about how to do
it better then I grow then you're on the
right side of motivation so a lot of
times we do things accidentally we're
trying to be clear and telling people
what's happening in the application but
accidentally we essentially judge their
lack of effectiveness and that basically
undermines motivation
so if it's informative and they grow
good news judgmental it's bad news
the next thing is that you want to
provide scaffolding for successful
growth throughout the lifetime of your
application so what we're going to talk
about more is that when you have a huge
consumer base people come in with
different degrees of expertise and then
as they engage in your app obviously
their building experience over time and
becoming more and more confident so if
you know that fundamentally people need
to grow or they're gonna quit and
experience then you have to realize that
you need to meet each person where they
are both from an expertise standpoint
and from an experience standpoint at the
point that they really need information
so you have to be really contextual
about understanding what's important to
people progressing and kind of given
that information when they need it the
last thing is is because growth is so
instrumental the people having
investment in an application part of
your communication strategy the way in
which you want to talk about your app
both in app and kind of when just
talking to people is you want to kind of
foreshadow for them Pass for growth and
how they can continue to develop the
longer they stay with the app that's
essentially where people get a lot of
value from things so that's essentially
a key part of your messaging and
communication so fulfillment of these
needs is essential in applications
because they're essential in life this
is not a model that's talking about app
development it's a model that's talking
about what leads to fulfilling enriched
satisfied consumers so when your
application leverages these truths about
motivation then you get lots of benefits
to all the things that you care about
as a business long-term engagement etc
etc so that's the general framework a
lot of times it's easier to understand
this when we go from the general
conversation to specific so I'm going to
talk about some of the apps that we've
worked with recently and kind of put a
little more meat on these bones so an
important topic that's a huge issue for
behavioral scientists is retirement I
don't know
it's basically everyone understands how
important it is to lifelong happiness to
prepare for retirement but in the States
only four out of ten people actually
have seen enough money so sixty percent
of the population is not prepared it's a
huge behavioral science problem because
it's something that you have to do for
the benefit of people and for the
country but no one really wants to
engage in it why don't they want to
engage in it well the first thing is
that unlike games and entertainment apps
saving money is not inherently fun very
few people on a Friday night when
they're reviewing all the options of
enjoyable things they can do think now
is the time for retirement planning so
when you work as a behavioral scientists
on this problem the first thing is that
anyone you talk to once doesn't want to
talk about the topic which obviously is
a challenge when we start looking at
retirement apps we ran into another
problem all retirement apps start with
what we would basically characterize is
terrifying math questions so they
basically ask you these two things they
first say when do you plan to retire and
the second thing they say is how long
will you stay in retirement when you
look at that closely what it really
basically boils down to is when are you
planning to die so if you wanted to
demotivate people that's essentially the
perfect construction because not only do
people not know the answer to those
questions but it makes them like fill an
existential crisis that they don't know
the answer and that death is impending
so retirement apps like their if their
goal has been to like terrify their
customers they're really on top of
things and horribly that is their goal
because essentially their model for how
to increase entire meant is to scare
people to essentially make them feel
that if they don't do this then horrible
things will happen to them if you
remember what we talked about earlier
about motivational quality that's what
we call external pressure where you're
basically trying to get actions by
scaring people instead what we want to
do is make people realize what the
benefit for them of preparing for
retirement is so we had a different view
than the traditional retirement industry
so how did we approach this first we
want to flip the script and basically
talked to the people using the app and
say it's not about math it's about
creating a foundation foundation from
living the life that you
one of the big disconnects that people
have when they think about retirement is
they don't realize that the person
they're gonna be in 10 20 30 years when
they retire is the same person they are
now so where we want to start the
conversation is basically what do you
love in life if you had more time more
money how would you spend that time and
money what are your passions what do you
care about this is diametrically opposed
to when do you plan to die it's
essentially saying why do you want to
live you know what do you care about so
that's where we started the application
script the second thing is once we got
people really fixed on that point we
wanted to make them more effective at
answering the questions we needed them
to answer to figure out what the right
plan was for them so we made the
language less jargon II made it more
colloquial tied the questions back to
the plan that they had already started
to make when they discuss what they
cared about their lives and it put
things in a much more comfortable way
for them to kind of intelligently answer
those questions one of the things that
you find when you take this approach is
that people feel much more support and
caring from the application in the
company because it's not trying to
terrify them anymore it's basically
trying to support them and help them
plan for retirement so the latest scores
shot up immediately when we worked with
their client they came to us so they
obviously felt some appeal for this
approach but then when we started to say
this is what our plan is they were kind
of nervous because their experience over
dozens of years of working in this field
was the longer you made the application
process the more people that quit along
the way and essentially asking people
what they wanted to do with their lives
lengthen the process and so even though
they believed in it they were nervous
about it success happily what we saw
when we finished the application is that
retirement savings were increased by
more than 400% versus the previous
design and as I mentioned previously
customer loyalty and appreciation soared
because now people felt supported in the
process of figuring out retirement
rather than scared another area that
we've worked in a lot is health and
fitness health and fitness also very
challenging maybe not as hard as
retirement which is the worst
but also very hard you know one things
we talked about earlier that where we
sit in the relationship with developers
is there are a lot of behaviors that you
see and the real question is why is
someone doing that fan exercise is
massive for this if you go to a gym you
see a hundred people they're all working
out so behaviorally they all look like
they're doing the activity that you want
that they're all successfully exercising
but what's under the surface is very
important to the prediction model for
how long they continue to exercise so
the question is is what can we do with
our framework to help find where each
user is and help them along their
journey to a healthier life so the first
thing you want to do is you want to
measure and understand where the
customers at motivationally and I'm
gonna kind of click through a number of
statements which basically characterize
different kinds of motivational quality
so someone might be exercising because
they were told they need to make changes
or they're gonna die this is close to
our retirement thing again where if you
don't do this horrible things will
happen the next one is I know I should
focus on my health I'll feel guilty if I
don't I know it's the right thing to do
not necessarily I want to do it but I
should do it the next statement is I
want to take care of myself because I
know it will benefit my quality of life
and the last one is I just enjoy having
a healthy lifestyle basically each of
these are a different step along the way
to higher motivational quality and what
we know by doing these studies a hundred
different times is that where you are in
this journey is predictive of how long
you're gonna continue to exercise
essentially the first statements that I
read have very bad results that's where
you hear people like that stats like
only 5% of people that start an exercise
program continue with it for more than
eight weeks on the far right you see
great outcomes these are the people that
run every day have happy healthy lives
and so the question is you know what do
you do about this problem because tons
of the people that come into
applications are coming to gyms sit in
the unhealthy space motivationally and
so as behavioral scientists they care
about people's well-being can we do
anything so first we understand where
they're at the next thing we do is if we
know they're in a place motivationally
that's
predictive of them continuing on with
exercise then we know that we have to
help them internalize greater value for
the activity that means giving them the
right content that supports their
competence communicates to them the
long-term value essentially tries to
make it argument experientially about
what the benefits of exercise are gonna
be because we know we have to
essentially move them within the
application to a different place
motivationally or they're not going to
stay around I mentioned this earlier I
can actually give you a push up example
so it's perfect
finally you want to avoid signals that
evoke evaluation or pressure as some
view looks like a pretty fit room in
here but some of you may have
experienced not exercising for two or
three years and trying to get back into
it what that feels like is you
oftentimes feel like a novice coming
back to an experience that you don't
feel expert around if you're in a gym
you're in an exercise app oftentimes the
assumption is you already know
everything about exercise you know the
right form you know how many to do you
know everything about it
obviously that makes people feel like
they lack competence so then when they
take their first baby steps into doing
something and basically an application
or a trainer says wrong wrong wrong
that's not how you do it then obviously
that's a barrier for people continued on
so again this is where you don't want
the feedback to be judgmental you want
it to be informational and oftentimes
judgmental feedback happens in very
subtle ways that kind of mentions
earlier where we'll do things that have
strong heuristic value like flashed a
red light to say that your forms wrong
but essentially what someone's seen
that's in a fragile state around their
competence is I'm doing this wrong and
I'm horrible to exercise and what's the
point I should eat potato chips instead
what they need at that point is support
and so really what this approach is
about is recognizing where people are
motivationally and being sensitive to
meet them at the place that they're at
to try to move them to a healthier place
around exercise that's the last thing I
want to talk about is a workshop that my
partner Scott did with calm which made
some of you may know as an excellent
meditation act and basically this is a
lot of what our work looks like where we
sat down with them understood their
product and
kind of brainstormed some future
possibilities for the application the
first thing that there was a lot of
ideas that came out of that someone at
Scott's workshop said you know my head's
bursting there's so many things that
came up with this model in place but
some of the things that were you know
most important was one let's try to
replace a one-size-fits-all onboarding
approach with content that matches the
specific motivational profile each
customer you can kind of see on the
mock-up on the right it's kind of some
suggestions for a way a more tailored
approach might be more appealing to
people coming into an application
instead of just saying let's meditate
would you like to meditate to reduce
anxiety to improve your focus to work on
sleep issues etc etc you can see how
that would make someone feel more
authorship more ownership feel more
effective build to find the content they
want it's essentially the thing that we
talked about earlier which is tailoring
things to people's more specific growth
interests the next thing is we measure
motivational quality when we work with
developers and so within the realm of
meditation it made perfect sense to say
the point we're trying to make is if you
meditate you see all these great
outcomes to your physical health and
psychological health so why don't we
take those measurements that we're doing
for development purposes and show them
to the consumers show them that once
they put in the work in their practice
they're getting all these obvious
benefits that they care about their
lives that's a lot of reason why people
come to meditation apps so that was an
exciting idea that everyone kind of
grabbed on to and then lastly
that same detail that we use to show
people that this is working also shows
us where our programs not working as
well as we would like it to so it might
be that we have these eight different
domains and three of them everyone that
you know essentially tries to reduce
anxiety gets perfect results and we've
crushed it it might be that in three
others it works for some people and it
doesn't work for other people's and it
might be in the last two that it's not
working for anyone this allows us as
developers to pinpoint where we most
need to add design features and then we
can start to triage well why aren't
these two sections working well is it
that people don't understand
are they ineffective do they not
understand the value
are they not seeing the benefits these
are not good feedback in all the issues
that we brought up before and so
essentially the point of these metrics
is to give us more precision about why
people are doing what they're doing in
applications so just a few takeaways
that hopefully you got from today's talk
one is that you can build loyalty by
authentically supporting your customers
basic psychological needs which are
autonomy relatedness and competence I've
been in literally over the last 10 15
years 5000 design discussions and I
understand how oftentimes your triaging
a problem and a lot of times you don't
want to find any solution that'll work
you know taking shortcuts is the wrong
term but you oftentimes get really
myopic about how to solve a problem
really what our recommendation is is
take a step back and try to understand
the foundations of consumer behavior and
motivation and say how do we solve this
design problem with that kind of greater
perspective because that's essentially
what's going to give you the best
long-term results next thing is that
reframing the app experience in the
context of these needs deepens
motivational quality and builds personal
value that lasts really it's a variation
of the same point that I made before
that there's basically ways to design
things that are much better suited to
setting up long term engagement a lot of
times we make choices as designers that
might solve a problem temporarily but
this is really the foundation of last
the third thing is collecting
motivational profiles things like
motivational quality and how the three
basic psychological needs are being
fulfilled and powers customization of
the user experience at scale oftentimes
what you'll find is there are three or
four or five profiles of consumers that
you can find in your application and you
can make intelligent choices about which
one's the sir first how to serve each
one of them then to do really good
benefits and consumer engagement very
quickly fourth remember the negative
effects of external controls on autonomy
even when building reward systems
there's a lot of you know a lot of app
design
has ties back to game design people
realized very quickly that reward
systems badges experience points levels
all these things are an important part
of game design and there's a way in
which those things can be employed
effectively in applications that support
people's narrative about the experience
but a lot of times when those things get
divorced and it's all badges rewards
levels and no understanding of what's
driving people's long-term engagement
the product it essentially has an
undermining effect on motivation and
engagement so you don't want to build
your apps engagement on a foundation of
sand you really want to connect to the
things gonna last lastly as behavioral
scientists that care about autonomy we
want to be autonomous supportive we
wouldn't want you to see this framework
as rules
it's supposed to be guidelines to kind
of inspire innovation help me to think
more creatively about how your
application can improve its engagement
so that's hopefully the spirit that has
taken in if you need any help figuring
out what questions to ask how to collect
this kind of data how to design more
motivationally please contact us in
immersive thank you very much
[Applause]